They have neither the sincerity
nor the passion
to implement any of them!
If you disagree with my observations,
it doesn't matter who you are...
SENIOR MATH CLUB
Hey.
Hi, we're looking for the
Archaeology Club.
Upstairs. Look for the Lit Club sign.
Thanks.
I THINK, THEREFORE I AM
At last, inquiring minds!
The Philosophy Club wants you.
New members! How long has it been?
My struggle was not in vain.
We're just heading for the
Archaeology Lit Club, actually.
Now don't be shy.
Shall we discuss existentialism?
Or perhaps you prefer Nietzsche?
Chem Club! How dare you
disturb our contemplation?
Better run, you guys.
You'll be there all day.
Show some respect,
you second-rate alchemists.
At least we do experiments.
Your ideas can't even be proved.
‘New poets! Draw energy
from clouds, light, storms...’
‘Show us the direction
humanity should take...’
‘A Copernicus for a new age,
to set us free...’
CQ! CQ!
This is a high school student from Japan.